all right against the
tall right-hander
kyle gibson
gibson making his sixth start of the
season
the best five start to a season that
he's had his whole career
he gets a ground ball right right off
the bat
especially in today's game when that's
the name of the game most people score
2-2 off the end of the bat left side of
the infield culberson
takes care of verdugo
lay off a pitch out of the strike zone
he goes down to get this one lifts it
out to center field but eli white able
to track it down for the final out of
the innings perez on one with a 571.
it's going gonna be shot toward the gap
long run hernandez [ __ ] got a nice jump
on it out number one that really kicked
off his career one-two pitch
that is in there for strike three
caught him looking so that's his first k
tonight well that's a good sign right
there if you can get that pitch all
night you know about three or four
inches inside
that's gonna certainly help out perez
that ball a little bit inside but called
the strike
and near the bottom in pitching here
comes the one two
yep there's another strikeout
back-to-back caves by martin perez in a
good first inning
he's running full here on the number
five hitter
swinging to miss runner going is the
throne attack got
[Music]
[Applause]
strikeouts and stolen bases right they
try both they get a strikeout but they
also get caught stealing
that tag going on the back side before
the handgun on the back christian
vasquez is now throwing out three out of
nine
so far this season
and even though he's not in the lineup
tonight christian arroyo has been able
to do a really good job at second base
which has allowed those guys to play
other positions
hernandez
not pleased with that strike three call
that's the first strike out of the night
for gibson
so a door opening just to crack here
back to back ball fours and brings up
xander bogarts who was all for one
gibson with the 02. swinging a miss he
struck him out
got him with a pitch that was down
bogart strikes out on three pitches holt
off cancer surprising none of us
fastball bottom of the zone called
strike three martin perez looking really
good
back in his old haunts he's a lot of
guys do wonderful things in the
community and and all of them get due
credit for that the one-two pitch is
strike three called he's dotting the
fastball as perez back-to-back
punch-outs five for martine they're two
down for isaiah keiner valetha on the
road also
tops in the big leagues
2-2 pitch sliders swinging a miss
and vasquez is out on strikes third
strikeout victim for kyle gibson
one two pitch and that one out to left
field that could be trouble drops in
base hit dowell got a good start out of
the box he's heading for two there's
nobody home at third base
and finally a bunch of red sox scramble
for third and then the throw goes wide
and gallow goes headlong in the third
base
inside the left field line well inside
the line and i don't know what happened
to verdugo he disappeared from our view
but it took him a long time to come out
of there with the ball and by the time
that he threw it back into the infield
was like a comedy the red sox couldn't
get the ball there were four different
red sox who had a chance to stop that
ball in time to keep joey gallo at
second base and none of them did
here's adolesce garcia the infield drawn
in for boston payoff pitch
and that one hit well deep to center
field and that'll be caught on the
warning track
by [ __ ] hernandez it's deep enough to
get gallow to the plate and the rangers
score the first run of the night
the sac fly garcia
just needed to put it in play into the
outfield and he does
the rangers building something here in
the fifth let's see how they play this
you know they get their best picture on
the bar now and a couple base runners
nobody out dev is in close at third base
in in front of the bag
and perez he's squaring to bunt
popped up
and it's going to be caught by denver's
that's a gift
that's a huge first out one man gone and
now is he conor felipe the shortstop
and gets it
rising fastball to put him away
and a big second out and now he's just
trying to get out of the fifth inning
unscathed it'll bring up their best
hitter nick solac
on the ground scooped up by gonzalez and
he gets out of the inning nice work by
martin perez
signaling that he wants it up
2-2 is coming down and that one
fouled away that was the slider
[Applause]
there you go that's what it's all about
right there
gotta like this
oh he just missed it you can't have it
kid yes you can 2-2 pitch and a swing
and a miss got him with a fastball
that's some pitching right there
that's the second out of the inning and
it will bring up rafael devers the
left-handed hitter
he rips that with a line driving to the
corner and out of bounds it gets up
against the 326
verdugo is in to score what an at-bat
and denver scolds a double to tie the
game at one garcia the runner at first
with two outs tied at one in the bottom
of the sixth trevino the battery is
singled and fly to left
oh trevino
takes one deep out to left field it is
gone a two-run shot
first long ball of the year for trevino
and the rangers lead 3-1
what a time for jose to go deep
off a picture he's never seen before
connor falefnow he's all for four
the 2-1
swinging a drive deep into center field
hernandez going back still going back at
the track he leaps into the wall and
it's gone
hernandez goes hard into the wall
a line drive home run for isaiah keiner
follett his third of the year and the
rangers lead four to one talking himself
more and more aggressively and then
came up with a big hit
he swings and misses here strikes out to
start the ninth inning well i'll tell
you one thing in the last four hitters
there's been a lot of fastball swung and
missed that vasquez the hitter
this one wafted out to short right field
long run
for dolly scarcity gets in the foul
ground to make the catch two away
2-2
got him swinging and this one is over
kennedy for the perfect ninth inning to
pick up the save and the rangers win the
opener from boston 4-1